ich habe absolut keine ahnung wie ich
das heutige video hier starten soll der
letzte nacht habe ich geträumt ich wäre
wieder im jahr 2016 und hat sich
aufgewacht bin hatte ich dann einen
kleinen ich will sich
nervenzusammenbruch nennen das wäre
völlig übertrieben aber ich habe auf
einmal alles infrage gestellt
und hab mich irgendwie nach der alten
zeit so ein bisschen zurück gesehen und
was auf youtube bezogen die alte zeit
für mich bedeutet ist einfach minecraft
[Musik]
wie schön es einfach ist
wie schön minecraft einfach ist ich war
jetzt viele haben einen kanal abonniert
wegen reactions und krassen gaming
videos extrem aufgeladen über emotional
am rumschreien keine ahnung was der
kabine auf einer einsamen insel
ich bin mitten im ozean hast du hier
vorgebaut sich das festland auf ich weiß
dass viele mal einen kanal abonniert
haben wegen blogs wegen challenges
vielleicht wegen anderen games aus
minecraft damals habe ich ja gut zu mir
die nato habe ich ganz ganz viel
gespielt nintendogs allerdings ist mein
kanal entstanden und groß geworden mit
minecraft und ich habe mir heute
wirklich gedacht
luca auch wenn minecraft nicht viele
klicks bringt auch wenn minecraft ein
spiel ist mit dem du damals aufgehört
hast weil du da keine lust mehr drauf
hat ist und ich wusste auch schon damals
hey das ist eine ganz blöde entscheidung
mit dem spielen aufzuhören weil alle
meine abonnenten wegen dem spiel auf
einem kanal waren
doch ich hatte einfach keine lust mehr
darauf heute war genau das gleiche nur
komplett umgekehrt und zwar bin ich
aufgewacht und hab mir gedacht ich habe
lust auf minecraft und auf meinem kanal
ist wahrscheinlich niemand mehr abonnent
der sich denkt hey ich hab den kanal
abonniert wegen minecraft videos war ich
das seit monaten seit jahren vielleicht
schon nicht mehr hochgeladen habe
allerdings hatte ich da einfach lust
drauf ist das mein stil
ich habe mir auf jeden fall gedacht
warum lebst du da nicht einfach ein
minecraft video hoch heute wenn du da so
lust drauf hast und wenn ich heute schon
so ein bisschen nostalgisch unterwegs
bin habe ich mir gedacht ich lass euch
daran teilhaben
das natürlich logisch wenn ich ein video
davon hochladen ist die insel aber ein
bisschen boring oder auch mal direkt
darüber schwimmen komme ich habe richtig
bock was zu entdecken ich habe richtig
lust auf dieses spiel
ich habe mir hier wirklich ich habe mir
hier gemacht sondern so eine schöne
heiße zitrone habe ich mir gemacht
das ich habe mein kreft so lange nicht
mehr gespielt ich kenne das alles gar
nicht ich wusste nicht dass es da unter
wasser solche welten gibt ich weiß nicht
wie lange das video hier geht es kann
acht minuten gehen es kann 15 minuten
gehen es kann auch eine halbe stunde
gehen ich habe einfach mir heute gedacht
mensch ich möchte sie in der höhle
fallen also teile runter ich glaube hier
ist der höhle oder da geh ich bestimmt
nicht rein ich wollte jetzt nichts
machen von wegen hey ich mache eine
reaktion auf die mädchen wg auf die
jungs wg
das geht gerade relativ ab ich spiele
morgens mit freunden das geht gerade
ziemlich krass ab ich habe mir heute
wirklich einfach gedacht
ich habe lust auf minecraft ich will
wieder dieses spiel rein und es ist so
schön dieses spiel
das ist wirklich unfassbar ich glaube
ich habe die
die richtige ästhetik von minecraft habe
ich nie so richtig geschätzt da schwebt
einfach ein blog scheiße in der luft ich
hab's nie so richtig gewertschätzt das
ist das ganz normale texture pack ist
das hier abkommen das kann man auch
abbauen und hält er es auch weil das
nicht so
[Musik]
doch er kann ich hier alles runter
fallen lassen da habe ich mir den weg in
die höhle zugebaut
naja ich hab mir auf jeden fall gedacht
ich habe da bock drauf und ich habe
schon immer auf youtube das gemacht
worauf ich bock ab und es war noch nie
so dass ich irgendwie gesagt habe haye
jeder macht jetzt pokémon taten openings
dann kaufe ich mir jetzt auch für 5000
euro pokémon karten ja sagt damals als
ich mit akinator und clever bord
angefangen habe das war die die gute
alte zeit wo jeder die spiele schon
gespielt hatte aber ich dachte mir hey
jetzt hab ich auch mal für mich entdeckt
ich glaube übrigens ich mache mir direkt
einen ofen weil ins dunkel wird dann
habe ich fackeln
ja ich habe auch keine kohle das blöd
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt ganz schön
also auf dieser kleinen insel das hier
ist in der hinsicht ein bisschen größer
als unsere staat insel
aber ich finde es ja eigentlich ganz süß
wir müssen hier noch so ein bisschen was
aufräumen
das ist hier alles irgendwie ein
bisschen durchlöchert guckt euch mal wie
schön das hier ist mit dem sonneneinfall
das ist wahnsinn ich habe dieses spiel
wirklich vermisst und heute wie bereits
gesagt ich hatte diesen traum dass ich
im jahr 2015 2016 wieder bin und mein
tag bestand daraus zur uni zu gehen und
danach einfach mit freunden online
minecraft zum zocken und hab ich mich so
ein bisschen habe ich mich so ein
bisschen nach gesehen bin ich ganz
ehrlich ich dachte gerade das wären
geist der mir auch ordentlich viele
bäume
[Musik]
das könnte mir aber ich höre auch
irgendwo noch ein schaf also es stimmt
das dass wir hier ein schaf schwein und
kuh haben
ich höre auch zombies ist nicht so schön
da ist das schweinchen können wir gern
meinen namen in die kommentare schreiben
fürs schweinen für die kuh dass das
schaf hallo meister schied man
danke freut mich auch nicht kennen zu
lernen haben unseren eigenen kleinen
kölner zu haben weil die hamburger zu
ich wohne jetzt in hamburg
das war auch eine sache die ich dann
heute morgen direkt infrage gestellt
habe
war das eine gute entscheidung mit
hamburg war das richtig ich brauche mehr
holz plötzlich habe ich einfach mein
ganzes leben in frage gestellt und ich
habe mich einfach danach gesehnt ja
wieder jung zu sein ich weiß nicht ob es
so ein bisschen damit zu tun hat dass
sich natürlich auch vor ein paar tagen
geburtstag hatte ich bin 25 geworden
sandra hat es mir in der neuen podcast
folge die ihr euch gerne auf spotify
anhören könnt ganz oft vorgehalten dass
ich mit 25 jetzt mehr als einmal warum
schild die hier alle bei mir in der ecke
jetzt hab ich mir gedacht sondern als
neuen podcast folge ganz auf vorgehalten
ich bin jetzt näher an der 30 als an der
alz als an der 20 danke dass du so mit
mir fühlst kannst du dich mal verbissen
hier die rutsche jetzt nicht hier so da
bleibt jetzt aber auch jetzt noch mal
hier stören ich muss jetzt ein bisschen
was machen dann hat mir das ganze noch
vorgehalten ich bin näher an der
allerdings habe ich ja schon ich brauche
eine axt ich stehe voll neben der ich
geb dir jetzt einen klaps das soll nicht
böse sein aber einfach damit du lernst
okay okay
er geht schon sehr gut es wird dunkel
was wollt ihr alle von mir ich sehe dich
auch wenn du woanders hingucken gut
sondern hat mir ganz oft ich bin jetzt
mehr und er 30 als an der vils an der 20
und das hat mir auch wirklich zu denken
gegeben und ich weiß einfach dass andere
influence einmal im alter plötzlich
kinder bekommen und heiraten und ich
denke mir ich sitze und ins spiel
minecraft aber es macht mir spaß und ich
weiß auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so
richtig wohin gerade mit meinen gedanken
jetzt kommt hier das schaf wieder an
[Musik]
ich hab nichts dieser shader macht alles
auch so unfassbar schön schaut euch das
mal an ich unter schaaf gucken zusammen
den sonnenuntergang zu fristen
das gras hierauf ich habe auf jeden fall
auf einmal alles in frage gestellten hab
mir gedacht ich habe einfach bock auf
minecraft ich mach das jetzt mein gott
jetzt welche fast rein gefallen mir
besser
das mal ein bisschen aus ich habe mir
meine schaufel wir müssen wirklich so
ein bisschen die inseln ein bisschen
schöner machen
auch jetzt habe ich jetzt einen knopf
gemacht oder was kommen wir machen war
da dran
da kann jetzt einfach drücken und dann
auch cool ich wollte meine schaufel
machen und um das ganz kurz einmal
abzuhaken das thema ich weiß dass dieses
video nicht mega viele aufrufe bekommen
wird ich weiß dass ich an diesem video
nicht so viel geld verdienen wie
beispielsweise an blogs oder keine
ahnung was aber ich weiß dass es mir am
meisten spaß macht aktuell und da habe
ich einfach gerade bock drauf
ich kenne das ja alles nicht mehr sorry
dass ich hier so ran somit die ganze
zeit so lost bin wenn ihr das bei
anderen youtube anschaut falls andere
youtuber überhaupt so minecraft letzt
place noch machen sagt 2012 wo kommt das
ja alles revolutioniert hat ja ich würde
einfach freuen wenn ihr auch so ein
bisschen bock drauf habt wenn ich euch
so ein bisschen daran teilhaben lassen
kann
an meiner ups an meiner freude hier
gerade ich mache mir noch mal eben so
ein schwert ich glaube das ist
eigentlich ganz gut falls sie gleich
monster's ball spielen auf der
schwierigkeitsstufe normal oder schwer
ich weiß es nicht aber ich glaube normal
und da kann man so ein schwert auf jeden
fall schon mal ganz gut gebrauchen
die holz spitzhacke habe ich keinen bock
mehr auf mein gott es schreckt mich doch
nicht so hab ich kein bock mehr darauf
die schmerzen weg
das heißt ich gesagt habe mein herz
alter schwede
ich sehe mich schon wieder im
uniklinikum liegen alter schwede du
blödmann laser luca 69 fragt nicht warum
jetzt sondern ein kleiner mini kurz die
autohäuser
ich sehe ihn gar nicht dass er so
schnell
ist denn hier los diese kann er so viel
da ist ein krieg dem elend ich besser
direkt bevor mir gleich oben alles weg
macht jetzt geht's los
ich habe mich richtig gefreut
ich darf nicht sterben ich darf nicht
sterben ich darf nicht sterben ich bin
ja auf der anderen insel gespannt da
müsste ich wieder rüberschwimmen ich
darf nicht sterben um ein gott leute ich
habe mich ja offen richtig schönes video
gefreut daheim esther schipper
ich habe mich auch richtig schönes
minecraft video gefreut
ja ich weiß dankeschön aber das bringt
mir gerade nichts was soll er denn
machen
er steht in rom wir müssen uns ein haus
bauen ganz ganz fix
ganz ganz fix aber ich brauche das
einfach mal so
und ich kann das doch nicht ich kann
doch jetzt nicht sterben
wollte ich kann doch jetzt sterben
wo es ab
die bürde brigitte
[Musik]
ich habe mich richtig doll auf dieses
video gefreut und ich dachte mir hey das
wird richtig cool
ich freue mich da richtig drauf so ein
bisschen alte zeiten
so ein bisschen wie der minecraft
spielen zusammen kommen so ein bisschen
reden
und jetzt werde ich hier komplett aus
meinen träumen gerissen
[Musik]
dass das schwein und da ist es dass die
kuh ich muss ein bisschen gucken
ich könnte jetzt natürlich dich töten
mach ich nicht alles gut
ich könnte natürlich jetzt die kröten
oder das schwein
dann hätte ich natürlich was zu essen
könnte dementsprechend meinen meinen
hunger balken auffüllen und könnte mehr
ja
da sind wir wieder schwimmen rüber zu
unserer insel
ich sehe da vorne schon das nächste
skelett stehen ich schwimme jetzt
direkten ganz ganz großen bogen und
werde mich instant ein kleines gemacht
dort oben begeben auch jedoch weckmann
ich will doch niemand haben liegt schon
eine spitzhacke anni die wollte ich
nicht auch manchmal hier sind sachen von
mir überall liegen sachen rum hier die
fackeln
wir müssen wirklich wirklich alles alter
du erschreckt mich wir müssen wirklich
alles ausleuchten oder ich schieße ich
höre schon wieder viele fliegende
gottchen ich stelle mich einfach nach
hier oben und beobachte alles so ein
bisschen da unten haben wir niemanden
wir haben hier müsste man hier minister
kommen wo ist das geld
mister zombie habe ich glaube meine
sachen wieder bekommen die ich verloren
habe
von daher ist noch mal mit einem blauen
auge davon gekommen
die sache ist auch keine kartoffel
gedroppt das cool ich bin ja ein riesen
kartoffel fan also viele sanierer
kartoffeln oder typisch deutsch
ich liebe kartoffeln kartoffeln kannst
du alles raus machen kartoffel quartal
kartoffelpüree kommissar kenne ich meine
kuh ihr werdet so kommt gar nicht klar
so den haben wir
alter schwede tut mir leid er geht
wirklich ladekran beckhams herz ich muss
gut aufpassen
die gar nicht gebraten
ein halbes herz habe ich geh wieder
zurück in meiner ecke leute ich habe
mich so auf ein auf ein ruhiges auf ein
ruhiges minecraft video habe ich mich
gefreut und hab mir wirklich gedacht
mensch ich hab da richtig lust drauf so
ein bisschen mit euch zu quatschen
so ein bisschen nostalgisch in die alten
zeiten zu gehen nach halo aber dich
alleine mit der kws aufnehmen aber wohl
nicht seine freunde kannst du da stehen
bleiben oder du kommst halt einfach ich
muss die recht vorsichtig sein
die halten auch immer mehr aus so weg
ich hab dich beschützt was sagst du dazu
[Musik]
mit ende mai noch bei 9
die uns passt auf
die coco dazu läuft auch mal weg er kann
euch in die luft sprengen
er ist tot die ku guck da einfach nur zu
was denkst du du bist ja das hab ich mir
gedacht jetzt brennen hier alles das
schön
ein neuer tag was sagt man da brauchen
abschuss richtig genau das sagt man da
auch das ist ja hier ist auch eine halbe
selbstmord fallen du lebst auch am limit
lebt alle am limit guck mal
und das war der blutige krieg hat er
hier alles kaputt gemacht hatte
ach gottchen wir haben ganz ganz viel zu
tun haben wir doch man die so verbrennen
die da unten nicht bei der warmwasser
jetzt verbrauchen verbrennt der körper
nicht die können auch bei tag überleben
oder das heißt wir müssen den club auf
jeden fall noch töten
und erst dann kann mir hier getrost aus
der erst dann kommen wir hier raus geben
weil ich will meine tiere hier nicht
immer ich will meine tiere hier nicht in
der welt haben wo die der ganze ganze
zeit gefahren ausgesetzt sind
vor gott gott gott gott gott da läuft
der endermann rum also wir haben
wirklich dafür dass wir so eine kleine
insel haben haben wir ganz ganz ganz
ganz viele leute wenn ihr lust habt
kommt morgen auf jeden fall noch einmal
verfügen sind das schildkröten
das ist doch keine schildkröten
[Musik]
diesen fast so schnell wie
wir müssen uns auf jeden fall um was zu
essen kümmern ich will mich komplett
vegetarisch ernähren von daher müssen
wir in der nächsten folge direkt unsere
farben machen wir müssen irgend etwas zu
essen kriegen ich will meine tiere nicht
töten
ich will die beibehalten schreibt mir
namen für die tiere in die kommentare
schreibt mir gerne und in die kommentare
wir euch das video gefallen hat mir hat
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
viel spaß gemacht ich bin ein bisschen
nervös ich bin doch ganz ehrlich wie es
während des videos hier bestimmt die ein
oder andere träne aus meinem arschloch
gekullert es war ein sehr emotionales
video für mich ich habe ganz lange kein
minecraft mehr gespielt von er bedeutet
mir dass sie wirklich gerade sehr viel
ich hoffe wir sehen uns morgen wieder
morgen wieder pünktlich um 20 uhr eine
neue folge minecraft mit luca und wir
sehen uns seid lieb zueinander ich habe
euch lieb
[Musik]